have one uh really good piece of advice
to share with you guys out there who in
like
similar situations me like you guys are
in an area where it's not that
you know good um i would say this bro
like
it doesn't matter um if you have to cut
them off
like good company is better than bad
company you feel me like
like because at the end of the day your
goals
is the only thing that matters you feel
me they're just gonna bring you down
trust me man good company is better than
bad company and no company is better
than
that bad company as well yeah yes sir
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um this dude over here is better looking
than me
and a girl would probably want to be
with him more than me and
it was just dumb things going on in my
head but it's like
hey that's what was going on in my head
at the time
and for me to sit down and just like
observe it without any judgment
allowed me to see like oh okay that's
going
on in the background let me let me work
on that
let me be more aware of that let me put
in some more effort to be able to
be more mindful and more present and get
past that
you feel me so like to me that's my
favorite form of meditation but
either meditation is fine just the fact
that if you can meditate at least 15
to 30 minutes a day you will see the
benefits
hi assalamualaikum brothers and sisters
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the edonya you are joined here
with fayette and myself rami is
missing in action he is working right
now but no worries we got our boy
uh sa ching such and such
touching that's how you say your name
right yeah such a man for everybody
yeah you went to high school with me
it's saturn but it's really such a
touching all right so we we joined with
the brother
and from what fire was telling me he
just reverted
is it true
when did you revert bro um so
funny story is uh the first time i was
thinking about islam
was i watched that video of yours back
in like
i think it was back in october or
november yeah
yeah man um ever since like
so basically i grew up in a christian
household right
in a south indian christian household so
like all my people
are christian the whole culture is
christian you know what i mean
but ever since i was a kid i always felt
like i was different
you know what i mean like i felt like i
never believed in really the jesus
concept worshipping saints i never
really believed in like
worshiping a son of god you know what i
mean so i was
so ever since seventh grade i was
agnostics
and right now i'm currently 19 and
since quarantine started last year um
pretty much i've been into the new age
stuff i was doing spirituality
meditating but um funny story is uh
since i look sort of middle eastern um
over here in new york a lot of people
confuse me as a rap but
you know what i mean so like i would
like get profiled sometimes
uh so like then i would be like what's
up with this whole islam thing man
because
um when i used to go to india right
there's a lot of muslims
over there as well there's a lot of
muslim brothers over there alhamdulillah
um so i i knew about muslims i've seen
muslims around here
you know i grew up with some african
muslim friends as well
but um i never really looked into islam
because in my family
um strict brown household you know like
we only
were very strict about the prayers and
not looking into other religions
but alhamdulillah um through quarantine
i was able to go on my phone
and you know watch your videos
download the quran app so i started with
the quran app
and um the first line um
uh what is it uh bismillah
for some reason that line like really
stuck with me bro like um like it's
saying god is the most
merciful the most forgiving like that
that line alone
just stuck with me and i was hooked ever
since man
so this damn so it's only been a few
months
yeah bro it's only a few months but
i've only really started taking taking
it seriously for like the last month or
so
that's you doing it is all that matters
yeah yeah i remember like a couple
months ago
he hit me up and we we got some calls in
bro i remember we used to you know
there were there was some stuff we uh
got some questions on like a lot of
people interested in islam
uh we kind of worked through some of
those things um just clearing it up but
you know at the end um i thought it was
going to take a couple calls right
um and then one day he hits me up and
he's like i'm keeping a low key but
i've taken this step and i was like man
ma sha allah
so you said this was um so this was
around the time that you saw
my video where i was basically
coming out coming out of the closet
letting people know
um pause but um
was bro did i send you the uh
cooldown app did you ask me about that
or is that someone else
um no so me personally
i just downloaded it yeah let me check
this out because i was because i was
feeling
you know i was lost i was feeling like i
needed some
some way to fulfill my life you know i
mean i was stuck in online school
and stuff like that um i knew i couldn't
really do anything until i graduate
you know in my situation so i was like
yo i need something right now
i don't have that i don't even have that
big of a social life right now i need
something to fulfill my purpose because
my heart's calling for it
yeah so i just downloaded the app and
yeah man like took off from there i i
even bought a quran i bought i bought a
quran off the
etsy.com
as long as it's a legit translation then
that's really all that you got you saw
hey did you see your ahmedi video
oh we can't hear you bro okay
yeah take take your headphones out i
think something wrong with your
headphones right now
there we go there you go we can hear you
um yeah yeah i did yeah yeah so it's
like
ahmadis they have their own translation
of the quran which isn't the real
translation
right and other countries like in china
they change a lot of verses
um so it goes without saying that you
want to go to a proper one
now i will say most of them are you know
legit
at least the proper ones but uh you
gotta know where to look i personally
i like quran411.com um
but yeah there's a lot of different apps
and websites now different languages too
yeah i'll be using the uh the kuramaji
that
it's pretty legit that's pretty legit so
bro
you say mother [ __ ] you up man but
you said that you read that first line
the bishop
and that just stuck yeah bro
um it's just stuff like i don't know
what it is man like i think it's a lot
just i don't know like i feel like it's
in my heart you know what i'm saying
like i told fire this when i had a call
with them
a couple months ago he was talking about
something about the fitra
and um i was telling him like i felt i
felt something in my heart
you know what i'm saying and like i've
seen other videos
talking crap about islam i've seen um
you know david wood
i've seen such guru people that are like
debating with islam i've seen all that
but
i've read as soon as i read the first
chapter of the quran like nothing can
nothing changed my heart like nothing
nothing you could say bro
can really that's what's up man and
that's
honestly i think that's uh that's just
us
coming back to what we already know like
fire was saying
it's the fitro bro it's like it's inside
of us and um it said that
islam is our is the natural religion
and the natural religion uh it
it resonates with i'm i'm
getting it twisted right now but um this
external religion like
you coming on to islam like the quran
and all these things like
this is external but then internal is
your feet that are internal is
what islam naturally is and that's why
it just coincides it
it resonates with each other that's why
when you read it it's like oh
there's something here you know and
i think i think too the fact that you
noticed that there was something off and
that like you were seeking
something else and then you actually you
know started taking steps in that
direction not knowing in
which direction you were heading but
just taking steps in that direction
that's what ultimately brought you back
to allah
back to the creator because if you think
about this
but this is me like realizing all this
stuff here in ramadan being in a dry
fast state meditating and all this stuff
but it's like if you really think about
it
we experience a lot of pain a lot of
suffering
and just a lot of traumatic things in
our lives ever since we were little kids
right everything that's in our lives
everything that we've been doing has
more or less been
a distraction from our pain and from our
suffering
the video games you play the movies you
watch tv shows you watch
the um friendships you had all the
things you've been doing there's very
little
that you could say you did it out of
just the pure love of doing
you did it more so because you were
trying to run away from the fact that
you couldn't be alone
you couldn't be by yourself because any
time you were by yourself all that pain
and all this stuff started coming up
and you just couldn't handle being alone
for more than a few minutes maybe a few
hours
it's like i don't know about y'all but
i'm speaking for myself and it's like
when i kind of did something similar to
this when i did the dopamine detox
that's when things began to uh clear up
and i was like oh
damn like behind all this pain there's
guidance
there's like something there that's been
trying to like guide me this entire time
it's just like i had to get through the
pain first i had to take that first step
and get through that pain and that's
what i feel like you did bro
it's like you took that first step and
you were like yo
i don't know what it is but i got to do
something you
hell yeah man yo it's a great thing that
you mentioned video games too because um
when i was in high school like my first
like until senior year
i was addicted man like call of duty
like all that you know
you cut off again
yeah he's going in but we don't hear
bro bro fix fix your headphones or take
them out or something
yeah my man you cut off my phone
you were going in bro but we hit you
yeah so you said that you were playing
call of duty
yeah so um i was always like just gaming
all night right i had um
friends friends friends
who were uh like you know always
just gaming all the time right just
playing around with their life all the
time
mind you they will get good grades but
me i i just didn't care man like
something about gay men it was such a
big coat for me now that i realized it
was truly a big
cult like you were saying um you know
what i mean
and yeah it's crazy that you mentioned
that because i was the biggest
gamer destiny card like biggest addict
bro
and now alhamdulillah i got over all
that
in the past year oh and and
understand like in video games
inherently aren't bad
it's just what you're using it for it's
like a knife
you can use knife for good to like cut
up some fruit cut up some meat
or you could use it for bad where you're
stabbing someone are you stabbing
yourself
you know what i mean so it's like the
video game if
let's say you understand what your
purpose is let's say you are an athlete
and you understand okay i need to
increase my reaction time i need to keep
my reaction time speed
very high up there well bro you can
actually use video games to
enhance your reaction time speed
but again that's that's a tool you're
using it for a specific tool you're not
using it like yo i'm about to play this
all night boy
it's facts man facts like
that's not it you know i mean it's just
not it it's
it's like it's just like drugs not now
that i think about it it's just like
weed alcohol but you know i mean like
people use that as a tool to to get away
from
toxic uh other toxic people
but at the end of the day like you said
like
um a tool is just a tool
like it's not true purpose you feel me
like
that's not what's going to get you to
your goal like it's just a tool fan
it's an escape bro but people don't want
to ask what they're running away from
yo so now that you've reverted
have you read the entire quran
no i'm not even a cap i have not read
the entire quran
um i'm on i'm on chapter three
uh but inshallah soon man
i keep you know i mean yeah
brother let me tell you something and
just take it babysit my baby step
and you bro even if it's like one line
as long as it's one line like bro i had
to learn that too
myself it's like when i first reverted
and like i was
fire was the only dude that knew that i
was muslim
and um at the time like i started to
read the quran
but it's like at the at the same time i
was trying to learn prayer
but i was making this excuse bro it took
me
a lot it took me like three maybe four
months before i learned
uh the entire salat prayer where i could
recite it from beginning to end
without any paper without anyone saying
it or anything like that i could
recite it perfectly and then even recite
the uh
the sooner part the sin of prayers that
you add on to it
right so it took me three to four months
bro
if you're not making excuses it can be
done in less than 48 hours
a perfect example there was a
revert that reached out the fire yet and
he basically he reverted because of the
conversations that he had with fayette
and bro within 48 hours this man
learned how to pray so
it goes without saying that it's like
when you truly decide on something allah
will make it easy for you
because like bro when i decided like
okay i'm gonna learn to pray for real
now it only took me a few days
so you do you little baby steps but
remember like the moment you decide
that's when things will like
infinitely get easier for you i want you
guys both to tell me one thing
since you are reverts that was a bridge
that you had to overcome
after reverting
oh man you want to go first i'll let you
go first bro
no i gotta it's dude bro i'm telling you
it's like
okay ask the question one more time so i
can
try to pull this out my mind i got you
bro so
youtube being reverse yourselves what is
one thing
that you really had to work with
overcoming and you did
could be i don't know typical stuff from
jihadia
drinking drugs
uh pork could be getting used to prayer
could be uh cutting people off anything
bro um okay so
this ain't that deep but i'll share it
anyways i'd say
um tattoos
you know like yes i internalized the
fact that
um tattoos are kind of pointless and uh
it was part of my jockey leah
but there's still like oh bro like i
still feel it inside of me like oh man i
want to get my entire body tattooed now
i'm not going to
but it's it's definitely a bridge that i
had to cross where it's like i had to
let that go
and leave it in the past
appreciate your man for sharing that
give me one reason
what and could be could be something
short like a simple line or two
could be something deep bro but what was
that thing for you
that consolidated that you shouldn't
when i actually realized what all my
tattoos
were which like i spoke about in the
video where i was ago my tattoos
are um it's a
permanent depiction of a temporary
emotion
of a temporary experience um but to make
it even more simple bro like when i
really sat back and like looked at my
tattoos
starting from the first tattoo all the
way to the last tattoo it has all been
um part of the journey in how
i was being brought closer and closer to
allah until the
the final two tattoos
that kind of i wanna say within like
eight to twelve months time before i got
another tattoo like i didn't feel pulled
to get another tattoo within those eight
to twelve months
but in those eight to twelve months
that's when i fully came to islam
and into allah so i mean
[Music]
that's what kind of did it for me where
it's like okay i don't need
the tattoos anymore because i've already
i've already come
to allah like now that i'm looking at my
tattoos like bro
i'll tell you all right here my first
tattoo of full sleep
okay it's samoan and polynesian
and it basically in simple terms it
it's the warrior it it depicts the
warrior from like the abuse that i went
through as a kid
and then going from there the um
second that too is uh i got my mom's
initials
obviously a lot of this stuff is gonna
sound like uh it's a little superficial
but
trust me when i say it goes a lot deeper
i'm just like keeping it very simple
um but i got my mom's initials because
obviously
a woman gave birth to me woman took care
of me wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
her at the moment
um then i got my sister something for my
sister on my back
because my sister kind of raised me and
stuck with me throughout the whole abuse
in my childhood
then the next tattoo that i had gotten
was uh this thing running down my leg
and it's an arabic actually
running down my entire leg now that says
uh all that there is and all that
is now that's when i was coming back to
that spiritual path after being atheist
for a long time
i was coming back to that spiritual path
and i was really
starting to experience the present
moment i didn't know much about god all
i knew was
things that i had been told previously i
never felt god i had never experienced
god
but i had experienced the present moment
and then from there i got that
that tattoo next tattoo after that
was um this one on my my arm right here
and it's basically took in
from a uh a buddhist phrase and it's
took it from like the middle of a
buddhist prayer where it's like it has
no um
there's no substance it doesn't make any
sense
but like i got it specifically for that
reason because at the time
mentally i was in this uh very weird
place where
i was trying to get past all the
programming all the uh
the weird stuff that i had been through
it
i was trying to get past it so that's
that's what kind of like brought me
through that
or not really probably but you get the
picture and then the next tattoo
after that was um uh
this an ankh on my neck
and the arm just basically symbolizes
eternal life which
if you think about it the hereafter the
akira
is eternal life with allah so that was
already like
one step even closer and then the final
tattoo that i got
was uh three dots on my uh
this not the sternum but the uh the
clavicle and the three dots basically
symbolize
uh my crazy life oh bro it could be
it could be but it definitely did not at
the time
uh what it symbolizes is uh my crazy
life which means that
i'm gonna either end up in jail in
hospital
or dead because of the lifestyle that i
lived
and i i'm telling y'all like the
lifestyle that i lived was because like
i was seeking something more and like
the only time that i would
feel like a normal individual that i
would feel alive is when i
did things that basically put me at the
edge of life like skydiving
riding a motorcycle at over 140 miles
per hour
fighting doing all these things like
drugs
so it's like bro all the tattoos led me
[Music]
to islam so it's like a lot of people
say like oh i should cover them up when
it's like dude like
i i don't see them as a bad thing
like i get it but i don't see it as a
bad thing because it's
what led me to where i'm at you feel me
i'm the listen bro uh one you're a ball
hog
two and we got like monsters left i
don't know
listen it was all good because we all
got value from it i'm gonna let you
answer but before i let you answer
romney's in the waiting room so let me
join
but we do got five minutes unfortunately
and then we gotta record with gabriel
ah bro no problem it's all good
but um so the question was um
what was the question again the question
was one main thing that you're proud
that you overcame
after becoming a muslim [ __ ]
man bro because i'm from greenberg right
so like
i grew up with a lot of latinos you know
a lot of weekends a lot of
black people barely any other dead seas
beside me you know or just blind people
in general so
mind you i only graduated two years ago
so
i go to cu so i go to community college
right and i'm out here sort of lowest
i'm so lost in my life
i switched on major two times my anyways
so the friends i had like before
the last six months before finding islam
right was mostly low vibrational meaning
like
every time they hang out with me it
would be just to hit me up yo sad still
snatching a little
smoke you know let's go let's go hit
this thing up you know it's got girls
the you know scott [ __ ] or whatever
you know what i mean it's just like all
right
i'm gonna hang out with you because
we're gonna go get lit together
because i'm insecure and i don't know
what i'm gonna do with my goals
feel me so yeah man every time and every
time i came back right
whether it was like two in the morning
three in the morning don't matter every
time i came back uh
there was something always in the back
of my head like yo i should have been
doing this
like i shouldn't be doing this bro like
this is not how like my parents my
immigrant parents wanted to raise me
feel me
like i should be going for my goals you
know what i'm saying because every time
i got high you know what that
if you guys you smoke before it
yeah bro space mountain
man like you feel me like every time you
get high you know
you're not yourself bro it's just like
every time you get high bro you go even
lower
facts facts you go even lower bro
xq life of rescue fox yo that guy was
staggered with something bro
i like him man he was spitting anyways
um
yeah man like so i felt like [ __ ] every
time and
and i believe all that was for a reason
now because
i believe that raised my mind and that
raised my
my uh my clitha you know i mean and now
i cut off
literally percent of them so i mean um
even though and any and i have one
uh really good piece of advice to share
with you guys out there who are in like
similar situations me like you guys are
in an area where it's not that
you know good um i would say this bro
like
it doesn't matter um if you have to cut
them off
like good company is better than bad
company you feel me like
like because at the end of the day your
goals
is the only thing that matters you feel
me they're just going to bring you down
trust me man good company is better than
bad company and no company is better
than
that bad company as well yeah yes sir
bro my bad football bro i have so many
questions too
how much time we got left we got like
two minutes bro
bro so how's your family taking this
she's bro i'm not gonna i'm not even
gonna tell most of my family bro
i mean i told my mom right
she's just like oh okay whatever you
know she's just like
whatever and she's always trying to be
honest i'm like jesus is the way jesus
is
the only way the kingdom of heaven and
all this i just said no never and my dad
he's cool with it
but if i tell my other family i don't
know
you know what i'm saying but but at the
end of the day me right now i'm just
trying to take things very slow
because i know some of them if i tell
them
um they might like i don't know try to
disown me or whatever
thanks yeah you don't need to bro not
everyone has to know
yeah it's a fact bro like i've always i
just realized that now too like
no matter what you do bro they're going
to hate
fox yo just next time you guys have uh
one of them weddings or them get
together just bust out in the thobe
i got you i'm god
be funny man
we are grateful to have you here man i'm
grateful to have you
on the path as bro as brothers in faith
man
and real talk it's um
i say that genuinely because i had a lot
of people reach out to me and say that's
me
and um i kind of didn't buy with it at
first but i realized that he's coming
from a genuine place
like we truly are happy for you man it's
like we understand
the peace that comes with being muslim
i mean bro oh man i don't know i have no
words to say but i really appreciate you
guys for having me on
listen i would appreciate it if it would
have been amazing if it could be a
little longer but unfortunately we have
another episode
but what i will say is imagine stay at
it bro i'd rather you
you know you do everything you got to do
behind closed doors
and nobody knows you're muslim then you
tell everyone you're muslim but not
really do what needs to be done
but you know people listening to this
don't take what i'm what i'm saying out
of context and
hide the fact that you're muslim you
know because you want to become like
those around you
but you got to do with what you got bro
and alhamdulillah you've been doing
exactly that bro uh you know salah are
working on your fast just trying to take
one thing out of another to baby step
and man may allah grant you the highest
levels of vagina bro i mean
i mean i mean well i just recognize you
now
your your handle name is uh sp is code
yes sir yes sir and yes sir
man all right bro it's better you
realize that 35
minutes in that nothing right all right
rami
i want you to end it off bro real quick
all right unfortunately i couldn't make
it but
i'm glad i'm here to end it
give my own experience with this because
when my mom
had gotten surgery she got part of her
liver removed
she was out of commission for a year
and the entire time like i didn't do
anything for her
i was just basically hanging out with my
girlfriend
going to parties doing drugs drinking
spending time with friends basically
ducking her and my sister
was taking care of her the entire time
now
my sister didn't say anything but like
after the fact years later i reflected
on that myself
and i was like damn like that was really
rough
you know that was really rough for me to
do that to my own mother
i'd probably be questioned about that on
the day of judgment and like
that's me being a self-reflective person
being able to see that but like if my
sister would have said
what i had told you to say like i'm sure
at that moment in time it would've hit
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm